le sujet il est important évidemment
enfin le sujet du bien-être et du
bien-être numérique évidemment est
important pour nous il est important
pour j'imagine toutes les plateformes
et c'est un sujet sur lequel on passe du
temps on réfléchit beaucoup à toutes les
solutions une des solutions en tout cas
sur lequel moi à mon niveau je peux agir
c'est de m'assurer que dans nos gestes à
l'échelle de la France on va s'assurer
de créer du contenu le plus qualitatif
possible pour que l'expérience sur la
plateforme soit entre guillemets la plus
génératrice de valeurs et quand on
travaille sur effectivement
promouvoir un événement autour du livre
promouvoir un événement autour du cinéma
promouvoir un des événements autour du
sport comment on le fait en ce moment
avec Roland Garros comme on le fera avec
le Tour de France comment on le fait
avec beaucoup d'eau d'événements
sportifs on s'assure en tout cas que la
qualité contenu est à la hauteur
c'est c'est ça la réalité c'est pas la
qualité de la qualité des contenus il y
a une petite partie c'est du pâté
d'alouette et de cheval il y a une
petite partie d'alouette et puis le
reste c'est du cheval le reste c'est de
la vidéo qui défile c'est de l'addiction
c'est des mots qui dorment pas c'est des
troubles du développement cognitif ne
dites pas que vous avez que vous allez
régler ça en augmentant la qualité du
contenu c'est pas une seconde pourquoi
ne prenez-vous pas l'exemple de la Chine
pour une fois et pourquoi ne limitez
vous pas comme le tabac est interdit aux
enfants l'alcool est interdit en vente
etc pourquoi ne limitez vous pas c'est
pas qu'elle se serait pas une une
nouveauté l'utilisation de votre
plateforme si ce n'est pour des raisons
d'augmenter le nombre de utilisateurs
donc de compter les recettes
permettez-moi de
d'être en désaccord avec votre premier
point parce que c'est mon travail donc
en fait je pour moi c'est important en
fait de d'améliorer la qualité et de
continuer à soutenir des des moments
importants à l'échelle du pays et de nos
assurer que la qualité de des contenus
soit la plus importante possible je
pense que ça c'est c'est un premier
élément de réponse ensuite on a beaucoup
de fonctionnalités qui sont à
disposition au sein de la plateforme et
sur lequel j'en ai parlé un petit peu au
début sur lequel on doit faire un
meilleur travail de communication et le
mettre à disposition les 60 minutes
auxquelles vous faites référence pour
les moins de 18 ans Tik Tok est la seule
plateforme à avoir pris cette initiative
donc
on n'a pas eu beaucoup de félicitations
pour ça mais on trouve que quand même
c'est une super initiative
et aujourd'hui trois quarts des moins de
18 ans ont une fonctionnalité de gestion
de temps d'écran qui est activé sur leur
plateforme
ça veut dire que euh
[Musique]
ça vous empêche pas effectivement de de
continuer à vivre l'expérience sur la
plateforme mais en tout cas c'est un
message important qui vous fait
réfléchir sur quel est le temps que vous
êtes prêt à accorder à cette expérience
sur la plateforme donc la fonction les
fonctionnalités aujourd'hui
vous permet d'être en contrôle de ce
temps d'écran on a le mode connexion
famille sur lequel on veut aussi
continuer à plus communiquer parce qu'il
est extrêmement puissant il permet aux
parents de d'avoir des des
tableaux de bord chaque semaine sur le
temps d'écran de leurs enfants de
contrôler le temps d'écran par jour
c'est-à-dire que si vous voulez donner
plus de temps de mercredi que le mardi
vous pouvez le faire de vous assurer que
vos enfants communiquent uniquement avec
leurs amis etc donc il y a beaucoup de
choses qu'on peut faire par
l'intermédiaire des parents et on a
besoin de construire cette relation avec
les parents aussi pour qu'ils soient nos
meilleurs alliés donc les outils sont à
disposition sur la plateforme et on doit
effectivement s'assurer que
on en fasse un meilleur usage
[Musique]
vous nous dit tout à l'heure que les
pouces les poussées de contenu
représentent sont une goutte d'eau par
rapport à l'ensemble de l'utilisation et
là vous nous dites on est en train de
travailler sur l'amélioration des
contenus pour que les expériences soient
plus enrichissantes etc
c'est pas vous allez pas me convaincre
deuxièmement vous me parlez du contrôle
parental si vous mettez cette action sur
le contrôle parental c'est justement
parce qu'il y a des problèmes et moi ce
que je pense c'est que les applications
comme la vôtre elle devrait pas se fier
sur le contrôle parental pour m'aider
milliers de raisons mais pour une
notamment et vous êtes certainement
beaucoup plus au fait que moi de ça
c'est que ça introduit une ségrégation
sociale évidente les parents au CSP plus
sont beaucoup plus contrôleur des
applications de leurs enfants à
commencer d'ailleurs par les par les
responsables des grandes plateformes qui
interdisent très souvent leurs enfants
carrément de d'utiliser des écrans mais
en tout cas les CSP+ sont infiniment
plus
vigilant que les CSP moins par
conséquent aux introduisez une
discrimination sociale en faisant ça
considérable ou la renforcez pour moi et
c'est pour ça que je vous demande par
exemple Nintendo le fait vous dites que
dans des seuls à le faire Nintendo le
fait d'une façon plus switch aussi sur
les 60 minutes donc il n'y aura pas une
protection by design de l'application
sur le temps d'utilisation ou sur
d'autres choses tout le reste excusez
moi mais ça n'est pas sérieux
design il commence par le 60 minutes par
jour
sur pour tous les mois de 18 ans vous
avez pas d'autres plateformes
aujourd'hui qui qui le propose au bout
de 60 minutes en tout cas ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que trois quarts des
moins de 18 ans conservent cette
fonctionnalités ne la désactive pas donc
c'est énorme c'est c'est significatif
non mais ce qui compte c'est le résultat
mais c'est là-dessus je voulais vous
interroger techniquement
je pense vraiment que vous avez la
possibilité de savoir
combien s'arrête d'abord ne serait-ce
que d'un point de vue
de des questions de pouvoir faire valoir
à vos annonceurs comment fonctionnent
les utilisateurs c'est fondamental pour
vous de savoir comment se comporte vos
consommateurs comme pour tout
entreprises et pas uniquement dans le
domaine de la technologie donc moi
j'aimerais savoir
s'il le faut vous pouvez nous le dire
par écrit après coup mais il y en a que
25% qui qui suppriment cette possibilité
d'être informé au bout de 60 minutes
mais combien s'arrête dans un dans le
quart d'heure mettons qui suit le
puisque les
neuropsychologues expliquent souvent que
c'est pas sur le moment même c'est parce
qu'on sait que ça va s'arrêter quand on
a un petit laps de temps supplémentaire
puis après on s'arrête comme quand on
dit tu vas arrêter la télé c'est jamais
sur le moment c'est rarement sur le
moment est-ce que vous avez la
possibilité technique oui ou non de nous
dire plus tard s'il le faut combien
au bout des 60 minutes ou presque ça me
semble important parce que mettre tes 60
minutes pour dire
vous savez il y a les dix commandements
depuis 2000 ans et pour autant il y a
toujours des gens qui tuent donc ce qui
est intéressant c'est de savoir ce que
ça produit derrière donc si vous avez
cette information techniquement nous
sommes preneurs
on reviendra vers vous effectivement si
nous reviendrons vers eux maintenant
puisque vous l'aurez répondez sur ces
questions je voudrais les prendre
en entonnoir et puis pour essayer de
faire apparaître et me faire comprendre
de ceux qui suivent nos travaux
si un enfant qu'on a dans son entourage
se met à s'enfermer dans sa chambre 12
heures par jour au bout d'un moment pour
relire tant qu'il est déjà lu tout
Proust puisque on dit toujours relire
Proust
est-ce qu'on laisse un gamin s'enfermer
dans sa chambre pour relire Proust 12
heures par jour tout un été
vous êtes pas psychologue clinicienne
mais ce qu'on peut admettre entre nous
qu'à un moment on lui propose d'aller
prendre l'air
je sais pas combien de temps on admet
qu'un gamin s'enferme et se met à lire
de la grande littérature mais il arrive
un moment où ça devient acceptable
au regard de ce que nous font remonter
les psychologues cliniciens au regard
c'est du qualitatif et pas du
quantitatif ou pas de l'objectif et
statistique me regarde chacun dans nos
circonscriptions de ce que peuvent nous
raconter des enseignants ou des
personnes chargées des enfants chargées
d'encadrer des enfants dans les collèges
par exemple
vous avez des familles et ça revient
souvent enfin en tout cas moi c'est ma
perception où vous avez des familles qui
lorsqu'elles sont invitées à venir
s'expliquer avec les enseignants sur la
difficulté du comportement d'un enfant
en classe ou d'un enfant qui va pas bien
les familles vous expliquent qu'ils ne
peuvent pas supprimer l'application ils
ne peuvent pas ils ne savent pas gérer
la réaction de l'enfant s'accite
ingérable de supprimer alors on va dire
les réseaux sociaux seulement nous n'y
pouvons rien si celui qui est en pleine
expansion et qui est sur quasiment tous
les téléphones des lycéens et ou des
collégiens comme nous avons ici des
visites au Sénat ça nous arrive souvent
d'accueillir des scolaires de
circonscriptions depuis trois mois je
pose la question systématiquement qui
n'a pas TikTok le gamin il ose même
celui qu'il n'a pas n'ose même pas lever
le doigt mais bon en gros tout le monde
a TikTok mais la rigueur tant mieux là
jusque là jusque là tout va bien
donc ma question c'est le 1h je
comprends mais à partir de combien de
temps vous pouvez admettre que c'est pas
tenable et donc est-ce que 4 heures par
jour c'est tenable est-ce que 3 heures
par jour c'est tenable qu'est-ce qui ne
vous donnerait pas le bourreau de dire
ben nous on coupe au bout de temps de
temps
c'est 60 minutes ils sont issus de de
d'études c'est à dire qu'en fait on n'a
pas décidé on sait pas à réveiller un
matin en disant tiens 60 minutes ça
paraît tranche rond faisons ça en fait
il y a eu beaucoup d'études avec des
experts des médecins des psychiatres qui
ont fait cette recommandation
effectivement sur un 60 minutes par jour
ce qui se passe c'est que quand le
mineur va passer cette étape des 60
minutes à 100 minutes il va recevoir une
nouvelle notification qui va lui dire
vraiment faudrait vraiment aller sur tes
outils de gestion du temps et commencer
à contrôler ton temps donc en fait on a
cette démarche proactive de renvoyer des
messages on a aussi un sujet de mise en
sourdine des notifications puisque les
notifications sont aussi une forme de
d'appel à aller consommer donc en fait
on met en sourdine pour les moins de 15
ans de 21h jusqu'à 8 heures je crois le
matin les notifications pour les est-ce
que c'est comment dire à ce que cet en
série si je peux le dire comme ça c'est
pas en option c'est par défaut c'est
automatique et il ne voit pas en
sourdine pardon
il ne le voit pas apparaître sur l'écran
exactement et pour les 16 17 ans c'est
de 22h à 8h donc en fait on a aussi agi
sur ce cette notion de notification pour
que la notification soit par un appel à
venir à venir
se reconnecter sur le téléphone donc en
fait on a des gestes pour essayer de
renvoyer et de rappeler l'existence de
ces de ces outils je suis assez d'accord
avec vous sur le fait que on sera plus
fort si la démarche elle vient du mineur
que si elle a imposée par les parents
néanmoins les outils de gestion du temps
et le mode connexion famille il est
quand même très intuitif sur la
plateforme donc on a la conviction que
ça s'adresse pas simplement un CSP plus
c'est que aujourd'hui jumeler pareil
c'est comme quand on jumelle un
téléphone avec sa voiture ou que
jumeler un deux appareils c'est quand
même pas complètement sorcier par contre
il faut que les gens le sachent et il
faut que les gens sachent que ce mode
connexion famille existe et donc c'est
aussi pour ça que nous on investit et
qu'on fait des campagnes marketing pour
ça au sein de l'application on a aussi
des campagnes avec des créateurs qui
vont faire la promotion de ces de ces
outils techniques de gestion du temps
donc ça c'est des choses dans le cas de
nos campagnes marketing où nous on va
investir on va acheter une prestation de
service et un créateur pour qu'il
explique effectivement que ces outils
existent après interdire
c'est compliqué d'avoir cette posture là
c'est à dire qu'en fait on est quand
même dans un pays de liberté
si la loi l'impose bien sûr qu'on se
conformera on se conformera à la loi
mais c'est compliqué en termes de
posture de dire Tik Tok va être accusé
de de censure chinoise
je sais pas quel est notre posture je
sais pas comment vous répondre en fait à
cette question je sais pas si on peut
interdire réellement ou imposer en fait
on est dans un pour moi dans un rôle
d'éducation et d'accompagnement qui est
notre rôle le fait de d'interdire ou de
limiter de vous-même décider de ne plus
émettre comme l'ORTF à l'époque à partir
de 23h personne pourra vous le reprocher
quelle serait la posture de Tik Tok
vis-à-vis des autres plateformes
mais c'est vous que j'ai là aujourd'hui
pour terminer là-dessus simplement
regarder des éléments que vous pourriez
nous apporter par écrit je vous cite un
travail d'une journaliste qui a publié
un ouvrage comme vous le savez en mars
2023 sur Tik Tok nous avons à ce stade
très peu page 161 nous avons ce stade
très peu d'informations sur la matière
dans le gouvernement que représente Tik
Tok affecte les utilisateurs leur image
de même ou leur incapacité leur capacité
pardon de concentration pour citer
plusieurs points d'interrogation
récurrence qui concerne les réseaux
sociaux à la fin de l'année 2021 les
Facebook file révélés par France Hogen
avait permis de lever un coin du voile
sur l'impact d'Instagram sur les jeunes
l'étude interne réalisée par facebook
révélait ainsi qu'Instagram avait un
impact nocif sur l'image corporelle et
bien-être des adolescents si les études
similaires ont peut-être été menées par
TikTok elle n'ont pas à ce stade était
révélé vous venez vous-même de dire que
le 60 minutes ne venait pas de nulle
part pourriez-vous nous indiquer les
études sur lesquelles vous avez fondé
votre décision et le la bibliographie
quoi oui sans doute voilà je pense qu'on
peut vous donner on peut vous donner les
éléments absolument
les défis dangereux
ça défraie la chronique régulièrement à
chaque fois on dit ah ben oui c'est on
n'avait pas vu on va supprimer ça et
puis six mois plus tard ça recommence ou
trois mois plus tard avec un autre défi
vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé en
Italie je suppose avec la fillette qui
est décédée jeu du foulard
il y a eu pas mal de d'autres affaires
de ce type et notamment en France et à
chaque fois Tik Tok dit ah oui
excusez-nous on va faire très attention
et aujourd'hui ça continue mise à jour
le
8 juin 2023 sur 20 minutes le journal Le
Défi Tik Tok a dégénéré le 29 mars
dernier à Cergy plusieurs adolescents
ont décidé de sonner aux portes
d'inconnus avant de partir en courant le
tout en filmant la scène pour les
besoins d'une sonnerie partie un jeu
lancé sur les réseaux sociaux
je sais pas si c'est le vote mais je
crois que c'est le vote mais comme le
raconte la Gazette du Val d'Oise ce
mercredi des habitants n'ont visiblement
pas apprécié leur petit manège et le ton
est monté des jeunes ont alors agresser
trois riverains deux d'entre eux aurait
été des victimes de coup de pointe
troisième c'est fracturer la cheville
et je ne suis plus en prie la fuite
avant l'arrivée des policiers etc etc
d'après nos confrères des vidéos
retrouvées dans les téléphones montrent
notamment l'agression d'un River les
jeunes qui auraient reconnu en partie
des faits ont été présentés à juge des
enfants vous en êtes où sur les sur les
défis dangereux
alors sur les défis dangereux je pense
que le
évidemment nos équipes de modération
sont mobilisées sur des un défi
émerge on a la chance d'avoir des
associations avec lesquelles on
travaille qui sont extrêmement
utiles dont la gestion et la la
visibilité et la prise de conscience de
l'existence de ces défis on a parlé de
l'enfance et enfance font partie de ces
signalures de confiance avec lesquels on
travaille et on en a beaucoup d'autres
et je dirais que ce qui fait notre force
c'est aussi notre capacité à réagir très
rapidement sur sur ces sujets là et puis
d'apprendre et de fournir des ressources
pour accompagner les jeunes sur la
dangerosité de ces défis alors le jeu
des sonneries est peut-être un peu moins
grave que le jeu du foulard mais en tout
cas le jeu du foulard
c'est quelque chose sur lequel on a
appris et quand vous tapez aujourd'hui
sur l'application jeux du foulard vous
allez avoir des ressources qui vous sont
proposées des informations qui vont vous
expliquer pourquoi
c'est un défi dangereux pour qu'il ne
faut pas le faire et donc on n'avait pas
accès évidemment à des contenus ou à des
jeunes en train de faire jouer du
foulard mais vous avez en tout cas tout
un toute une explication de oui c'est
une bêtise
donc nous notre enjeu il est évidemment
de fournir ce type de ressources sur
chaque jeu dangereux
identifié et d'être le plus rapide à
supprimer ces contenus la plateforme et
ça c'est c'est une obsession de nos
équipes de modération pour protéger
évidemment les mineurs
merci
le filtre bold glamour je vous fais pas
de dessin vous connaissez ça aussi bien
que moi la présidente de l'association
Guy en France avec laquelle d'ailleurs
je crois vous travaillez notamment
s'interroge dans un article du Figaro
sur le fait d'interdire ces filtres
mineurs on en connaît toutes les
conséquences quel est votre position
là-dessus
alors le sujet de
des filtres et est un sujet extrêmement
intéressant parce que
au-delà des filtres beauté qui
effectivement sur lequel on peut avoir
un point de vue et un point de vue
personnel je dirais que c'est c'est pas
l'usage
de la plateforme c'est à dire qu'en fait
le la plateforme TikTok le principe
c'est l'authenticité c'est à dire de
faire des contenus on va raconter une
histoire authentique et on va se montrer
sous un jour authentique si on est dans
une posture ou dans un jeu
c'est pas un contenu qui devient viral
parce que c'est pas ce que les gens
attendent donc c'est vrai que le sujet
des filtres sur les vidéos il est il est
probablement moins impactant que sur de
la photo mais je dirais que c'est ces
filtres beauté ne sont probablement pas
des
sujets de popularité ou de viralité
réellement sur la plateforme c'est pas
ce qui va générer le plus de vues sur la
plateforme et le sujet du de l'effet il
est important pour nous pour améliorer
une expérience et et c'est amélioration
d'expérience elle nous permet de plutôt
de nous transposer dans un univers de
nous transposer dans dans une thématique
plus que sur des sujets de finalement de
beauté
probablement je voudrais que je vérifie
s'il est aussi il est toujours sur la
plateforme je dirais que pour qu'on le
supprime il faudrait qu'on ait une
raison majeure après à titre personnel
je suis pas complètement fan de ce
filtre mais ça n'engage que moi donc
tant qu'il crée pas de dégâts ou de
dommages ou qu'il y a pas de de plainte
je sais pas trop comment répondre à
votre question à vrai dire mais en tout
cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la finalité sur Tik Tok c'est pas de ce
qu'on appelle le beauty shot c'est à
dire que c'est on vient pas sur Tik Tok
et on n'est pas populaire sur Tik Tok
parce qu'on fait des vidéos où on est
joli ou des photos parce qu'on est jolie
j'ai l'impression que pour vous tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde il est
gentil
les psychologues les chirurgiens
esthétiques etc nous disent il y a un
problème majeur il y a maintenant plus
de d'adolescents de 18 à 20 ans qui
consultent qui font des consultations de
chirurgie esthétiques que de personnes
âgées
les
psychologues nous disent que l'époque de
construction identitaire l'adolescence
Québec de construction identitaire
entraîne à partir de ces schémas de ses
filtres des problèmes majeurs de
dysmorphophobie
sans compter les problèmes de dépression
etc c'est un vrai fléau
j'ai l'impression que vous regardez ça
depuis votre salle de pub votre bureau à
Tik Tok en regardant
une version complètement théorique je
peux vous dire que nous pas seulement
d'ailleurs avec les associations etc
mais dans notre boulot de sénateurs
auprès de la population générale on est
en permanence
le problème des réseaux sociaux et en
particulier et très très fréquemment
au point que comment dire mis en exergue
et vous ne vous rendez pas compte du
nombre de personnes supposons que ça
représente 1% de vos centres pour cent
quand vous avez 20 millions
d'utilisateurs en France c'est des
centaines de milliers de personnes je
crois que vous ne vous rendez pas compte
de ça sur les filtres sur les les
identifications des des comment dire
à des
canons de beauté etc c'est un vrai moi
je vous dis mon sentiment c'est que
c'est un vrai fléau et que vous n'avez
pas l'air de le mesurer en fait je
trouve je suis étonné que bol de l'amour
soit toujours et ce genre de filtre soit
toujours sur l'appli alors permettez-moi
juste de vérifier parce que je n'en suis
pas complètement certaine donc on va
vérifier si il est toujours sur
l'application
après ce que je veux juste vous dire
c'est qu'en fait sur TiK ToK on vient
pour se divertir on vient pour s'amuser
et on n'est pas sur
sur une vidéo où on va se s'embellir
entre guillemets si elle n'a pas
d'histoire elle n'a pas d'intérêt elle
ne sera pas virale donc en fait le
filtre en tant que tel il est
intéressant s'il apporte une expérience
donc on a des filtres qui sont des
filtres de quiz on a des filtres qui
nous permettent de d'enfier le casque
des Daft Punk et de se mettre en scène
quand il y a une notion de gamification
ces filtres ont une efficacité virale un
filtre qui embellit à pas vraiment
d'histoire à il y a pas vraiment
d'histoire à raconter donc en termes de
viralité je questionne la viralité de de
ces filtres mais bien sûr qu'on minimise
pas le l'impact l'impact de ça vous
savez par parallélisme des formes le
milieu de la mode il y a une quinzaine
d'années a fini par se sentir dans
l'obligation de de mettre en oeuvre des
codes de bonnes conduite sur le fait de
ne pas mettre en avant des mannequins
dont la maigreur extrême viendrait
imprimer des canons de beauté qui font
du dégât après psychologiquement
donc la prise de conscience et la
possibilité de considérer qu'on a un
rôle volontariste sur la diffusion de
telle ou tel type de valeur
pourrait parfaitement et personne vous
le reprocherez au contraire venir
spontanément et si ça n'est pas une
plateforme de prendre la décision seule
de crainte que les annonceurs les
abonnés à y voir ailleurs enfin il y a
une responsabilité sociale qui est
énorme énorme
et qui est le corollaire de votre succès
quoi qu'il pendant de votre succès
sur le rapporteur
il vérifie Game Boy
alors les problèmes de
désinformation
newsguard que vous connaissez
probablement note une forte présence de
contenu faux sur TikTok 20% des vidéos
apparaissant dans les résultats de
recherche du réseau TikTok sur les
principaux sujets d'actualité
contiennent de la més information
d'après newsga selon Shin Labé
l'explication tiendrate à la modération
majoritairement faite par intelligence
artificielle et un algorithme qui
valoriserait les contenus faisant réagir
évidemment vous n'êtes pas les seuls
vous l'êtes et donc davantage et donc
davantage les contenus faux
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez deuxième
question il s'agissant de la modération
des contenus pourquoi a-t-il fallu
attendre les signalements de newsgard
pour que ce soit retiré les contenus
glorifiant les actes d'exaction du
groupe Wagner qui contrevenait pourtant
clairement aux règles d'utilisation de
Tik Tok cette défaillance elle aussi
explique-t-elle par le recours à une
modération par l'intelligence
artificielle et non à une modération
humaine
voilà deux questions
oui
Michael vallée me
montre cette information dans une autre
audition
newsgard 40 minutes pour tomber sur une
fausse info
alors
je ne sais pas je ne connais pas cette
étude de news gare je n'en connais pas
le la fiabilité
concrètement ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'en matière de désinformation
c'est je vous parlais au départ de nos
règles communautaires la désinformation
fait partie de ces communautaires hyper
clair que on n'autorise pas la
désinformation et donc à ce titre les
équipes de modération suppriment les
contenus qui sont de la désinformation
on travaille avec des vérificateurs de
faits qui font partie de l'international
fact checking network dont l'AFP qui
nous permet de vérifier un certain
nombre de faits
donc aujourd'hui
on travaille main dans la main avec
l'AFP notamment pour nous assurer que
les contenus sont sont des contenus
juste et vrai et effectivement on
supprime tous les contenus qui sont de
l'ordre de la désinformation
on a pris un certain nombre d'actions au
moment de la guerre en Ukraine aussi qui
qui sont des actions intéressantes qui
permettent de labelliser les comptes de
médias qui sont contrôlés par l'État
donc aujourd'hui on en a plus de 120 de
compte médias qui sont labellisés par
les nous qui sont labellisés médias
contrôlés par l'État qui permettent de
aux utilisateurs d'avoir aussi une
lecture plus juste de des informations
qui sont diffusées par ces par ces
comptes China Daily fait partie de ces
de ses comptes
sur la guerre en
Ukraine
et sur le sujet de la Russie en
particulier Tik Tok a été la première
plateforme à bannir suite à la demande
de l'Union européenne
Spoutnik et Russia Today donc on a eu
une action
directe de bannissement de ses comptes
et la plus rapide parmi toutes les
plateformes donc je crois qu'on est on
montre quand même par un certain nombre
de gestes notre mobilisation sur le
sujet j'ai probablement des chiffres à
vous partager sur le nombre de contenus
de fake news qui ont été supprimés
[Musique]
en termes de désinformation on a
supprimé
4191 vidéos
qui étaient des fake news dont 78% qui
ont été identifiés de manière proactive
donc voilà et nous vérificateurs de fait
on a plus de d'une trentaine de
vérificateurs de faits qui vérifie
l'ensemble de ces faits ce qui se passe
aussi c'est que on sur certaines vidéos
sur lesquelles
on a des doutes et on n'a pas on
n'arrive pas à un accord avec les
vérificateurs de fer on fait apparaître
une mention qui dit
fait une vidéo non
partageant des faits non confirmés donc
on a aussi la capacité de faire
apparaître ces mentions là donc on a on
est on est particulièrement actif et
puis on est très sensible aussi dans des
périodes
sensibles comme les périodes d'élection
par exemple les élections
présidentielles on a travaillé avec le
SIG pour nous assurer que on fournissait
toutes les informations utiles aux
utilisateurs avec un guide électoral
avec des informations sur ou voter
comment voter comment faire une
procuration etc qui semble-t-il a été
utile parce qu'on a eu plus d'un million
3 de
personnes qui ont utilisé ces ressources
donc voilà on est vraiment mobilisé sur
le sujet et et c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un sujet qui est pris au
sérieux donc je sais pas
quelles sont ces stats et d'où sort
cette étude mais en tout cas
je peux vous dire qu'en termes de de
procédure et de partenaires on est
plutôt assez bien équipé
merci
en 2021 le groupement des associations
européennes de défense des consommateurs
à déposer une plainte auprès de la
Commission européenne contre Tik Tok
elle lui reprochait notamment d'exposer
les utilisateurs mineurs à des vidéos
sexuellement suggestives dès leur
inscription est-ce que vous savez où on
est cette plainte
je ne sais pas où on est cette plainte
en tout cas je peux vous dire que ce
type de vidéo est contraire à nos règles
nos règles communautaires et donc
modérer et que ça fait partie des
premiers contenus qui vont être
supprimés par l'algorithme puisque
l'algorithme va
identifier très rapidement que ces
contenus de son nom conformes donc
je peux pas vous dire où on en est sur
cette plainte mais ce que je peux vous
dire c'est qu'en tout cas c'est contenu
sont ne sont absolument pas acceptables
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle sexuellement
sujets parce que quand je suis je
n'étais pas utilisateur de Tik Tok mais
j'y suis allé pour les besoins de
l'enquête je peux vous dire que quand
vous soyez paix les contenus sexuels
vont suggestifs
tout dépend de la définition mais selon
la définition ils arrivent extrêmement
vite et ils sont là
mais je veux bien vous croire à ce
moment-là je vous encourage à les
signaler vous appuyez sur la vidéo
pendant une à deux secondes et vous
pouvez signaler et vous avez une petite
case qui s'appelle nudité et et voilà
c'est parfois plus je suis sexuellement
quand c'est pas de la nudité totale que
quand on s'en est je reconnais que c'est
pas de la nunité totale mais ça veut pas
dire que c'est moins sujet et c'est pas
acceptable donc effectivement c'est ça
doit être modéré
est-ce que vous vendez vos données
et à qui non nous ne vendons pas nos
données les données sont utilisées
uniquement pour
nos propres besoins servir nos campagnes
publicitaires ou travailler l'expérience
utilisateur
est-ce que la pratique du Shadow banning
est toujours en usage sur Tik Tok est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire son intérêt
toujours en usage qu'est-ce que vous
entendez par Shadow banning le fait de
ne pas supprimer
des vidéos mais de les mettre de le
contraire du meeting si vous voulez
c'est à dire le fait de les
rendements visibles de les dégrader de
façon que elle soit beaucoup moins vue
voir très très peu en fait ça c'est
l'algorithme qui qui va le mettre en
place pour des vidéos que l'on considère
comme nocive si répété c'est à dire des
vidéos sur de des vidéos de régime des
vidéos de fitness intense ou des vidéos
qui si elles sont proposées dans la page
pour toi
de façon répétée elles peuvent être
pour le bien-être mental de
l'utilisateur
mauvaise donc en fait
je sais pas si on peut appeler ça du
Shadow banning en tout cas l'algorithme
va traiter ces vidéos là de façon
différente et les proposer en moins
grande ombre et en tout cas les
intercalés avec d'autres vidéos et puis
le principe de baisser la visibilité
aussi c'est sur des contenus plus
matures donc on en parlait juste avant
des contenus plus matures ils ne seront
pas visibles dans le dans les flux des
mineurs par exemple donc vous avez des
vidéos qui sont catégorisées et selon le
niveau de de maturité elles seront
moins visibles ou pas visibles du tout
pour des moins de 18 ans
oui mais on est bien d'accord que vous
avez encore des centaines de milliers
voire des millions
d'adolescents qui annonce qu'ils ont 30
ans ou 40 ans et qui ont accès à
l'ensemble de votre contenu
malgré vos précautions malgré
l'algorithme malgré les interventions
humaines il y a encore d'ailleurs vous
le signez dans vos statistiques je crois
que la dernière stratégie que j'ai vu
c'est pas rage moins de 13 ans 05
millions donc vous avez encore 500000
c'était une statistique qui date de
quelques mois pas d'aujourd'hui mais pas
vieille vous avez énormément de
d'utilisateurs mineurs qui ont déclaré
et un âge supérieur que vous ne pouvez
pas repérer c'est normal tant qu'il y a
pas un contrôle d'âge par double
anonymisation ou autre donc aujourd'hui
vous avez énormément de
de failles vous avez énormément de
mineurs qui se font passer comme majeur
que vous ne repérez pas je peux pas vous
dire j'ai pas de stade pour appuyer ce
point-là ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que on va communiquer sur des données
très précises dans le cas du DSA sur sur
nos audiences on sait que on a
la moitié de notre audience qui a
plus de 25 ans
on a concrètement deux tiers de
l'audience qui a entre 18 et 35 ans
donc et toute façon c'est pas trop dans
notre intérêt de de
pas être précis sur ça puisque notre
modèle on en parlait tout à l'heure
notre modèle
publicitaire nécessite d'être
effectivement plus juste sur sur nos
audiences donc
ça fait partie du travail de nos
modérateurs de nos assurés aussi que on
a en tout cas un respect à minima de
l'âge légal des 13 ans et ensuite
c'est compliqué effectivement de dire un
utilisateur tu n'as pas
tu n'as pas 19 ans tu en as 17 mais
peut-être qu'on arrivera effectivement
avec une réflexion collective à avoir un
niveau de contrôle supérieur à celui là
aujourd'hui à celui qu'on a aujourd'hui
à titre personnel est-ce que vous
trouvez normal que les gafams soient
interdits en Chine et TikTok autorisé
partout sauf en Chine d'ailleurs
franchement je suis pas une experte de
la Chine donc j'ai beaucoup de mal à
répondre à votre question
pour avoir une opinion sur le fait que
les gafams que toutes les plateformes
concurrent de TikTok soit éthique
d'ailleurs aussi soit interdit en Chine
ça vous paraît
on sait pas qui a le tout ce que je
pourquoi je pose la question parce que
les gafam protestent contre ça mais Tik
Tok ne proteste pas
qui est interdit dans certains pays je
trouve ça très injuste aussi donc oui
dans l'absolu on Ta philosophiquement je
suis pour la liberté d'usage de parole
et effectivement que on offre à tous les
utilisateurs du monde entier les mêmes
choix après il y a probablement des
raisons qui me dépassent et je
ne suis probablement pas la personne la
plus compétente pour répondre
précisément à ça donc si vous êtes pour
la liberté de parole
vous condamnez la censure lourde lourde
lourdes du Parti communiste chinois sur
douille une société appartenant au même
groupe que le vote et sur l'ensemble du
de l'Internet chinois mais puisque vous
êtes pour la liberté de parole je
suppose que vous condamnez je suis
absolument pas experte de du sujet de la
Chine
je ne connais pas cette censure en fait
je ne sais je j'aimerais j'adore me
prononcer sur les sujets que je maîtrise
et que je connais celui-là je ne connais
pas donc je permettais moi de de ne pas
me permettre d'émettre un avis bien sûr
que philosophiquement la censure est une
mauvaise chose
après je ne permettrai pas de
d'intervenir sur un sujet que je ne
connais pas vous ne connaissez pas le
fait que douille
vous connaissez douille quand même
dites pas que vous connaissez pas la
censure massive de do Yin qu'on peut pas
trouver une vidéo sur les Ouigours sur
le Tibet etc c'est c'est perdre tout le
monde le sait et vaut mieux que
quiconque donc je vous demande
simplement je pense pas que vous
puissiez vous réfugier derrière
l'explication je ne connais pas la
situation en Chine je cette situation on
la connaît vous la connaissez aussi bien
que tout le monde de Guinée massivement
censuré je demande simplement si vous
condamnez ça ou pas visiblement vous
n'avez pas l'air de le condamner
je ne sais pas s'il y a la censure sur
doing en Chine je n'ai jamais ouvert
l'application doing en fait donc je
lisais les journaux quoi si vous le
savez pas et vous êtes la seule et vous
êtes spécialiste des plateformes
française je suis comme ça Thomas je
crois que ce que je vois et en
l'occurrence l'application doing je ne
l'ai jamais ouverte donc je je ne sais
pas s'il y a de la censure je n'en sais
rien mais vous savez quand même je
suppose que Tik Tok est interdit en
Chine je sais surtout que Tik Tok opère
dans tous les pays du monde sauf en
Chine après il ne perd pas parce que
vous avez décidé de ne pas opérer mais
parce qu'il est interdit en Chine et
est-ce que vous trouvez ça normal est-ce
que vous condamnez le fait que tiklok
soit derrière en Chine c'est quand même
ennuyeux pour une société ça vous prive
de pas mal de d'utilisateurs potentiel
franchement je n'ai pas le contexte sur
sur cette interdiction ou pas
je ne sais pas je sais pas que ça me
gêne pas c'est à dire que encore une
fois je ne connais pas assez le dossier
pour
pour pouvoir me prononcer le dossier des
Ouigours vous avez entendu parler est-ce
que vous condamnez ce que pas mal
d'experts appellent le génocide des
ouigo en Chine ou en tout cas la
politique de répression vis-à-vis des
Wiko en tant que citoyenne et en tant
que personne oui bien sûr
bien j'ai terminé
pour rester dans le sujet j'ai posé la
question ce matin monsieur Garandeau et
comme vous êtes tous les deux
salariés de Tik Tok je voudrais essayer
de vérifier auprès de vous une
information
la formation sur laquelle Tic-Toc France
n'a pas donné de réponse la
sollicitation de la journaliste qui l'a
publié je vous relie l'extrait enfin je
l'ai lu ce matin
tous les salariés les confirment
si Tik Tok ça il parle des relations
question avec la Chine avec la maison
mère donc les salariés au dire d'anciens
salariés les salariés au quotidien sont
en permanence en contact avec les
employés chinois de by dance qui joue un
rôle clé dans la validation des projets
et des procédures
je saute certains passages parallèlement
certains salariés ont été briefés sur la
manière dont ils doivent parler de
l'entreprise en public selon les
informations du média spécialisées
guizmodo l'un des principaux
commandements promus par le document et
de contester les liens entre tient
Tic-Toc en Europe et que sa maison-mère
en Chine ouvrez les guillemets minimiser
by dance minimiser l'association avec la
Chine minimiser l'intelligence
artificielle ferme les guillemets
fantasy textuellement partie des
éléments à retenir de ce document
celui-ci propose par ailleurs certains
éléments de langage clé en main comme il
y a beaucoup de désinformations autour
TikTok en ce moment la réalité c'est Tik
Tok n'est même pas disponible en Chine
ma question est simple est sans
suspicion aucune vous êtes là depuis peu
de temps enfin un an
avez-vous été confrontés à ces éléments
de langage avez-vous eu en main ou
avez-vous été destinataires d'un
document interne ou de tout autre façon
qui qui vous qui soit similaire de près
ou de loin avec ce que relate cette
journaliste non voilà mais je vous pose
la question personnellement vous pouvez
pas répondre pour les autres donc vous
non très bien
j'aurais une remarque
sur le temps passé vous nous dites tout
à l'heure il y a 25% des il y a 75% des
des jeunes concernés qui conservent
l'alerte mais comme je vous l'ai fait
remarquer ça ne nous dit pas combien de
personnes grosso modo s'y conforme dans
les minutes qui suivent
de la même façon sur les infox ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que que vous
ayez supprimé tant de dizaines de
milliers de vidéos que vous puissiez
démontrer que sur tel ou telle sujet
vous avez pris soin d'invisibiliser un
modèle ou de supprimer certains modèles
ou que l'algorithme ne propose pas dans
des bulles de filtres d'enfermer les
gens sur sur des comment dire des sujets
précis qui font l'objet de beaucoup de
mes informations c'est une chose mais ce
que nous n'avons pas et de la même façon
il faudrait que vous ayez une personne
tierce extérieure qui puisse vous
auditer pour pouvoir objectiver tout ça
ce que nous n'avons pas c'est le fait de
savoir combien il en reste à la fin ce
que vous êtes une entreprise jeune mais
tant qu'il y a trois ans on n'est plus
évaluer que vous avez tant de
pourcentage de d'infox ou de mes
informations en ligne newsgard qui est
quand même assez reconnu sur la place
d'un point de vue européen quand il nous
dit on met 40 minutes en moyenne pour
tomber sur une une info fausse sur une
afox ou une mes informations
ils essaient de l'objectiver bon vous
pourriez faire une contre expertise ou
demander à un autre de répondre à ça ce
qui nous manque dans ce que vous nous
dites c'est pas tant le fait de savoir
que vous avez des modérateurs
heureusement vous avez des modérateurs
mais c'est la question du résultat à la
fin c'est dans des politiques publiques
ce qui compte c'est pas de dire que
l'État informe les gens sur la question
de la cigarette c'est de regarder
combien on a de cancers combien de
personnes qui se mettent à fumer combien
on a qui arrête et ça c'est des
questions statistiques de quasiment de
politique publique et c'est ça qui nous
c'est ça qui nous intéresse ça je
voulais vous dire et qui sont
probablement disponibles dans nos
rapports de transparence donc on va on
va regarder parce que dans la mesure où
la désinformation fait partie de nos
règles communautaires et que l'on combat
la désinformation et que donc ces
contenus sont modérés et par notre
algorithme nos outils et par nos
modérateurs humains ont communique à
travers ces rapports de transparence
trimestrielle l'ensemble des contenus
qu'on supprime et comment et à quelle
rapidité on les supprime et dont
24 heures et par signalement etc donc on
a un certain nombre de données dans ces
rapports de transparence qui qui sont
et combien il en reste parce que de la
même façon qu'il n'y a rien d'infamment
à avoir fait l'objet d'une cyberattaque
à avoir perdu telle ou tel type de
données à cette refait avoir par tel ou
telle porte dérobée sont des choses sur
lesquelles il faut communiquer pour que
ça bénéficie aux autres de la même façon
il est impossible à 1 milliard et
quelques utilisateurs que vous n'en ayez
pas et je pense que personne ne vous
demanderait le zéro faute mais de savoir
que tous les moyens sont mis en oeuvre
et qu'on et qu'on progresse au fur et à
mesure est un élément est un élément
essentiel
il y a une question à laquelle j'ai pas
eu de réponse ce matin et Monsieur
Garandeau a aimablement envoyé vers vous
est-ce que vous payez des journalistes
pour qu'ils prennent soin de faire du
contenu sur Tik Tok
non d'accord
c'est pas notre modèle en fait notre
modèle nous c'est d'accompagner des
cantons enfin journaliste ça peut
s'apparenter à une personnalité publique
une personnalité publique elle va venir
sur la plateforme parce que elle a un
enjeu de visibilité avant de en livre à
faire connaître un spectacle donc pour
répondre à la question à laquelle n'est
pas répondu dans un article de la
semaine dernière je crois le monde ou
Médiapart je crois c'est plutôt le monde
par exemple quand un journaliste qui est
sur le service public sur Inter et sur
France 5 par ailleurs de très très
bonnes émissions lorsque Augustin
Trapenard publie autant de vidéos qu'il
en publie sur Tik Tok en expliquant je
suis allé regarder Tik Tok ça permet de
ce site Tik Tok ça permet cela enfin si
il est pas payé il a tort entre nous le
le modèle économique c'est que une
personne publique par exemple lui ce
qu'il en retire comme on dit en
sociologie dont-controdon il n'y a
jamais rien de gratuit dans la vie mais
ça peut ne pas être monétisé le
contredon c'est la visibilité pour la
personne publique et en fait c'est un
échange de procédés je sais pas s'ils
sont de bons de mauvais procédés mais
c'est un échange de procédés c'est là
qui est le modèle économique entre la
recherche de visibilité pour une
personne publique ou un journaliste ou
et vous la qualité du contenu c'est ça
le marché en fait le ce qui est
intéressant avec Augustin Trapenard
c'est que il a compris en fait qu'il
fallait pas opposer les modèles et que
en fait grâce à TiK ToK on pouvait faire
lire des gens et le faire lire des
jeunes et donc il est arrivé très
naturellement sur sur la plateforme et
effectivement parce que c'est un super
ambassadeur parce qu'il est crédible et
parce que en fait il est il est juste
dans ce qu'il fait on a décidé
effectivement de le faire parler dans
notre campagne de communication sur
booktok donc on a eu une campagne de
marque où là dans le cas de cette
campagne publicitaire là pour le coup il
a été rémunéré mais pourquoi on a choisi
Augustin ah on a choisi Augustin parce
que il était présent sur la plateforme
et que il était crédible sur le sujet du
livre donc ensuite il est arrivé dans
une campagne marketing mais c'est pas
l'inverse se qui s'est produit
vous avez dans le cadre d'une campagne
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait une
campagne publicitaire mais l'accent sur
un sujet par exemple en fait on a acheté
du média pour un certain montant on a
fait un spot télé dans lequel on
explique en fait booktok c'est vous qui
allez payer du temps de
publicité sur d'autres médias donc on a
Inde voilà exactement dans dans certains
ouvrages ou certains articles sur Tik
Tok le fait que visiblement il y a
quelques plateformes ou quelques
comment dire des personnes qui diffusent
du contenu qui ont regretté après coup
de ne pas avoir qui ont comment dire qui
ont trouvé que finalement Tik Tok les
arrangés eux aussi même si vous étiez
concurrent parce que vous payez du temps
d'écran chez eux enfin c'est comme quand
je dis n'importe quoi si si un groupe
quelque chose qui appartient au groupe
TF1 se met à faire de la pub sur Canal+
on va on va chez le concurrent pour
chercher on achète sur Instagram on
achète sur Youtube on achète sur toutes
les plateformes et donc dans ce cadre là
vous avez fait une campagne de
communication pour booktok sur d'autres
supports et vous avez et ce journaliste
on a indemnités
absolument je comprends qu'il n'est pas
voulu répondre à l'article la semaine
dernière parce que même si ce que vous
décrivez dans un cadre précis vous venez
nous le décrire de manière assez précise
et claire
je comprends l'enthousiasme en
l'occurrence c'est c'est il faut quand
même refaire l'histoire c'est à dire
qu'en fait auguste entre athénin est
arrivé sur la plateforme comme plein
d'autres sont arrivés sur la plateforme
comme Joël Dicker c'était arrivé sur la
plateforme comme Antoine Dupont comme
plein de d'athlètes plein de comme Eric
et Ramzy soirée sur la plateforme comme
et en fait ils y viennent parce que
c'est aujourd'hui on est un média et que
on est en outil au service de plein de
choses la grande librairie à son compte
sur sur la plateforme libération arrive
sur la plateforme le monde fait un
travail formidable sur la plateforme
vous pourriez même parler de certaines
institutions parlementaires
j'osais pas vous faire la front mais on
a adoré leur contenu en tout cas mais
nous on est pas payé pour on a adoré
en tout cas la traîne West Anderson
était très bien trouvée puisque c'est la
tendance du moment il est important pour
les gens de savoir quand il y a la
petite mention publie reportage dans la
moindre gazette locale qui est payé pour
dire du bien qui n'est pas payé pour
dire du bien j'entends ce que vous me
dites monsieur Trapenard n'est pas payé
aujourd'hui quand il s'enflamme dans ses
vidéos TikTok pour booktok mais comme on
dit chez nous on dit chez moi ça a eu
payé enfin ça a eu payé c'est une
indemnisation qui est somme toute
modeste et vous aurez sans doute
probablement accès
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
je voudrais juste quand même rétablir
l'effet c'est il a été choisi sur cette
campagne parce qu'il est crédible sur le
sujet booktok parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'il publie et qui publie des
choses de qualité et qu'il a une
relation hyper intéressante avec des
créateurs booktok qui ont d'ailleurs
fait sensation au festival du livre de
Paris parce que voilà il a il arrive
aujourd'hui comme toutes les maisons
d'édition on a 60 maisons d'édition sur
la plateforme qui aujourd'hui sont
crédibles sur le sujet donc Augustin il
a été choisi dans notre campagne de
communication parce que il est il est
crédible sur le sujet mais mais c'est
pas il fait pas des contenus Tik Tok
forcés voilà d'accord
alors une dernière pour la route merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président
non c'est un sujet qui me préoccupe et
j'ai posé aussi la question ce matin
c'est la question de la cybersécurité
extérieure externe de l'application et
et de Tik Tok vous êtes peut-être au
courant de ce qui s'est passé il y a
quelques semaines pour une application
de commerce en ligne chinoise pin du
haut du haut qui s'est retrouvé avec un
malware qui permettait à certaines
personnes d'extraire les données de
l'extérieur à la fois sur l'application
en Chine mais aussi sur le développement
international que connaît cette société
donc moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
question de savoir si aujourd'hui Tik
Tok serait
à transférer
illicitement ces données vers la Chine
ou vers je dirais à la demande des
autorités chinoises je pense qu'il y a
un risque qui serait quand même
commercial extrêmement lourd la question
c'est celui de la vulnérabilité de tous
les supports et toutes les bases de
données notamment la vôtre qui compte
des milliards d'informations
personnelles de la part d'attaque
extérieure de groupes de hackers de gens
on dit que les données personnelles sont
leurs noirs ou leurs blancs de la
société de l'économie actuelle
quel est les moyens j'imagine important
que vous mettez en termes de
sécurisation de vos données et questions
que je pose à me dire mais c'est
compliqué de le dire est-ce que vous
êtes victime d'ACTA d'attaque est-ce que
vous êtes capable de les contenir est-ce
que vous les recensez est-ce qu'elles
font l'objet aussi d'un signalement
parce qu'en France et allemand quand
une base de données aussi importante que
la vôtre est attaquée on signale un
Annecy qui donne son aide c'est pas une
honte au contraire pendant longtemps
beaucoup d'entreprises renonçaient à le
signaler parce que on craignait le
préjudice d'images aujourd'hui c'est
quand même mieux de savoir que tous les
jours d'ailleurs en France des centaines
de milliers de données
s'envolent on ne sais où par le biais
d'attaque et pas seulement de rangeons
rend son logiciel mais de vol plus
récentes de données sans sans
destruction de ce qui se passe donc quel
est l'état aujourd'hui de la
cybersécurité le fait moi je veux croire
de bonne foi les dirigeants quand ils
disent on les transfère pas on respecte
les règles internationales sur les
transferts données mais la capacité à
résister à une attaque extérieure c'est
pas la même chose que donner ses données
que de laisser la porte ouverte avec le
risque d'être cambriolé ou quels sont
les serrures quelles sont les bars de
fer qui sont mis devant les fenêtres vu
l'importance des des données que vous
détenez
c'est une question évidemment
stratégique hyper intéressante mais très
technique et je ne suis pas moi-même une
expert de la cybersécurité ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que j'ai le
sentiment quand même que avec la mise en
place du projet Clover que
Erica rando a dû vous expliquer ce matin
avec la souveraineté numérique avec un
tiers de confiance qui sera annoncé
prochainement qui qui va sécuriser aussi
tout le stockage de données personnelles
en Europe
on va cranter quelque chose aussi en
matière de cybersécurité
après je évidemment je pense que le
sujet de la cybersécurité concerne
toutes les entreprises aujourd'hui
puisque toutes les entreprises
manipulent de la donnée donc ce serait
bien improbable que ce soit pas un sujet
important chez nous également mais je
n’étends pas expert du sujet je ne
m'aventurerai pas dans une réponse
hasardeuse et incomplète et c'est pour
ça que je vous posais le cas de la
dopine du haut du haut qui est une
grande société
chinoise et internationale et qui est
très soucieuse de cybersécurité
elle-même s'est retrouvée plus le
coffre-fort est grand plus il attire des
convoitises elles-mêmes c'est
visiblement trouvé chargé d'un malware
et avec des défis massives de données
qui a fallu reconnaître pour le dire
autrement depuis que vous êtes là vous
n'avez pas eu connaissance de d'une
attaque massive ou très préjudiciable
qui aurait touché tip-top ou TikTok
France dans les années précédentes
depuis que vous êtes là pour ce que vous
pouvez dire vous depuis mon arrivée chez
Tik Tok je n'en ai jamais entendu parler
et après je pense qu'il y a aussi c'est
probablement et là je vais peut-être
m'aventurer sur un sujet que je maîtrise
mal mais dans la mesure où justement on
a pas vraiment d'API ouverte et que les
API sont ouvertes que pour des
chercheurs aujourd'hui vous minimiser
minimiser aussi les risques c'est à dire
que le risque de cyber ils sont aussi
plus importants quand vous avez plus
d'API ouverte donc mais vraiment je n'en
ai absolument pas entendu parler donc je
suis désolé
souhaitez-vous rajouter juste pour
question quelle est l'entité chez vous à
quel niveau s'occupe de la cybersécurité
globale c'est-à-dire est-ce que ça se
passe au Royaume-Uni est-ce que ça se
passe aux
îles Caïmans est-ce que ça se passe à
Los Angeles qui est qui assure
globalement parce que c'est pas un
travail décentralisé c'est un travail
quand même qui mérite beaucoup de moyens
donc qui est en charge de ça le
géographiquement en tous les cas
je vais vérifier cette information j'ai
envie de vous dire Cora kinan qui est
notre patron la sécurité au niveau
global donc je j'imaginerai que c'est
lui mais je préfère qu'on vérifie et
qu'on revienne vers vous avec la bonne
information est-il quelque chose que
vous auriez souhaité ajouter avant qu'on
peut-être juste vous dire on a assez peu
parlé de contenu et et on je voulais
quand même repréciser le fait que les
équipes de Tik Tok en France sont
vraiment mobilisés sur
l'accompagnement des marques sur des
secteurs prioritaires que sont la
musique le sport le divertissement l'art
de vivre les contenus éducatifs
et et que notre engagement est sincère
et que quand on choisit des événements
auxquels s'associer que ce soit le
Festival du Livre de Paris le Festival
de Cannes qu'on soutiennent Roland
Garros qu'on soutiennent le Tour de
France qu'on soutienne le l'événement de
eSport récents le majeur de canter
strike ce sont des engagements qui sont
sincères et qui sont vraiment portés par
une compréhension de notre communauté et
de ce qu'elle attend donc voilà vous
avez le droit de pas me croire mais en
tout cas je voulais quand même vous le
dire parce que c'est ce qui anime le
travail des équipes elles sont
mobilisées à
s'engager sincèrement sur sur faire
croître cette écosystème et faire
croître cette communauté d'utilisateurs
avec des contenus toujours plus
qualitatifs toujours plus engageant
toujours plus pertinent et voilà c'est
vraiment ce qui nous anime au quotidien
donc voilà je voulais juste rajouter ce
point là
[Musique]